you say andy dufresne is not the
protagonist in the shawshank redemption
that's correct uh technically the
helpful way to think about the
protagonist
is the one who changes the most
and has the most agency and impact
on the change so um in that story
andy for sure drives the narrative
i mean he is a freight train of hope
all the way through that movie um he
hopes right in the beginning he hopes in
the middle and he hopes at the end and
he has a little bit of a doubt here and
there but for the most part
he's non-stop hope he dug himself out of
that damn prison with like a spoon or
something you know ridiculous or i guess
a rock hammer
um red the morgan freeman character
is um i mean it's not just that he's
narrating but it's also significant that
he's narrating because he starts
in despair and he says and they get to
the middle
and he's kind of picking up that this
guy andy and they've already been there
15 years at that point
picking up he's this guy andy's all
about hope and he goes hope
you can't hope in here it'll get you
killed in here right
um and that's that part of us that
um considers hope versus despair
um and that movie represents um
red in that movie is the protagonist and
he represents
how part of us can realize that
when we choose hope in no matter what
situation
especially when it's really bleak like
it is in that film
we actually liberate ourselves and we
free ourselves
to the point where there's a character
named brooks
and i really like that name brooks where
he gets
out and um the old guy
is so you know accustomed to that
other people and is so he kind of is
sort of a
happy-go-lucky character but like
he doesn't have enough hope and optimism
to be able to sort of rebuild his life
and so he turns right back to despair
and ends up killing himself
really beautiful turn and counterpoint
to this idea of hope versus despair
but no for sure i would analyze that
movie
with morgan freeman's character
red being the protagonists and one more
thing about that
story is that when they um
i believe the way the book ends which is
really wonderful
it ends with
morgan freeman or not morgan freeman the
red character in the book
just saying i hope i hope he's basically
learned to hope
and you don't know if he ever sees andy
and to me that is sort of a deeper more
resonant
lesson that like
it's easy to hope if you know you're
gonna get it
the rub is can you hope can you believe
can you be open
when you haven't gotten it yet and you
don't know if you're ever going to get
it
and when red learns to do that even
though he hasn't gotten
a reconnection with andy to me that
really hits hard
so i believe they did that in the actual
movie version and
um people were pissed off they didn't
like it
so they think they did they re-shot the
ending where they actually reunite and
people loved it so
you know um we're in service to the
audience and i think the audience
loved seeing
hope be overtly rewarded
to them it landed more deeply so when
stephen king
wrote the book it was a novella okay
it's part of a wonderful novella called
different seasons stand by me that movie
was it was a movie it was a great story
called the body
that's kind of like the the rob reiner
film but a little darker and more
interesting
um and uh so that and then
apt pupil is another one there's like
four stories and i think three out of
the four
were made into um movies wow
and i understand that you said something
about and
you did a video on your youtube channel
about uh how the law of attraction
powers the shawshank redemption and um
we can put a
link to it below here um our video but
you feel that the
maybe the title of the movie hurt its
success in the initial
release yeah yeah for sure in my opinion
and one of my writing partners is one of
the top marketing
minds in hollywood um so it doesn't mean
that i'm always wrong or he's a little
bit like he's
he's good so i have a pretty good feel
for marketing stuff
and my opinion is that when you have um
an unusual title like what the hell does
that even mean shawshank redemption
everybody knows what redemption means
but nobody knows what shawshank means so
um
the job of marketing is you're beginning
to tell the story you never want to
confuse people you can intrigue them and
i think that's why they justify a title
like that
is that it's intriguing in a way um
and in this case it was built on ip that
maybe people were familiar with and so
they were kind of
you know letting it go but like
the marketing campaign and the title you
choose is the beginning of telling the
story
and the better way to tell the story is
clear this is what my story is
it's a story about this or that you know
um so
that's ideal um but you know sometimes
you know the coen brothers always have
kind of funky sounding titles but like
you know the cone brothers movies get
sold because of mostly them and their
brand and their
sort of style their super power so um
you know there's certainly exceptions to
the rule but i think if you
take shawshank redemption and you give
it a different title
it makes a much bigger splash earlier on
i mean it made a big splash later
because of the reaction
but i think um there were much better
titles than that
and i think the book was the book like
ava gardner or something read it
okay we're sorry the other other actress
okay yeah and then the shawshank or
something
rita hayworth and the shawshank
redemption which is
fine for a novella you know um i guess i
don't know anything about
book marketing um maybe no difference at
all there but
in movie marketing there's so much noise
um
you absolutely will get a bigger
audience when you have a great title
and it cuts right through the noise in a
way that
totally beautifully positions
the audience for the rest of the story
and it's the beginning of the story that
you tell so
like a knife you want a cutting through
the noise
when you broke down the shawshank
redemption in your video
you talked about letting go of outcomes
and not being attached
if we think of a writer how should they
let go of
outcomes or maybe they shouldn't maybe
that's something that's
not that they shouldn't never be too
free-flowing with
letting something go well
um
they should always let go should they be
completely free-flowing
pretty much um but not so like
loosey-goosey where you just kind of
wander around aimlessly right
there's what we want for sort of
to cross our next career milestone as
quickly as possible
we want to have a clear sense of where
we're going
and conviction towards it and
a joy and an ease and a lack of
attachment and we don't
ultimately it's about that
process of getting there the um it's
like the way i talk about sometimes is
that it's a um
it's a treadmill you know you're
you're jogging on the treadmill and it's
a beautiful treadmill and once you get
to one milestone guess what there's just
another milestone
and then once you get to that second
milestone guess what there's another
milestone
right so you're already on the damn
treadmill so this idea of i'm going to
break in
well you write a screenplay today you've
already broken in
essentially are you getting paid for it
yet no
but the paradox is the less attached to
it and the more you're there just to
serve your audience as powerfully as you
can
the quicker you'll cross the milestones
that get you to the point where they're
paying you lots of money
you also broke down in your video victim
energy when it comes to the law of
attraction and
attracting sort of victim circumstances
versus empowerment energy
that's right how do screenwriters do
that
oh wow uh you ever heard of this thing
called twitter
um actually you see both on twitter
really wonderful
positive powerful energy and lots and
lots of
victim choices i can't make it to
hollywood because of this
excuse i'm to this i'm to that i'm to
the other
um they don't get me
woe is me i have no power it's just it's
really a fascinating
choice that um a habit that people have
of giving away the power
giving away the power giving away the
power when we have
the choice to do the opposite i'll take
the power i'll take it off you know
i'm responsible i can choose yes
hollywood has bias
yes some groups are more favored than
other groups yes
yes yes it's all true and you can
succeed
despite that how you go apples to apples
you're trying to do this
you're seeing what's already out there
with this you figure out a way to close
that gap
you position yourself as the best person
to do the next
you know thing in this genre the person
who's gonna
write horror in a new way or this in a
new way or that in a new way and if you
do that they don't care what you look
like where you came from
at all you need to deliver the goods and
in fact
if you are related to a celebrity or
studio head or whatever and that door
is wide open for you if you don't have
the goods you're not going to get work
either this idea that nepotism is what
fuels
all these things it's bs i mean it's a
factor but it's this much of a factor
what's really a factor is
delivering the goods and if you got the
goods they don't care where you came
from they don't care who you are
any type if you've got the goods they'll
be happy to work with you and will try
to sell you
and if you have all the connections in
the world
and you're not delivering the goods
guess where you go director jail
writer jail you get nothing and that's
exactly what happens there
and these ideas of that hollywood's is
closed place is bs
because of director jail you know what i
mean it's like you got to put up
what's true is that you're only as good
as your last picture that sort of thing
i mean that's
um that's a negative way to spin it but
that's the truth i mean it's like
um the internet makes pretty much
anybody you want to get to accessible
you know one way than another you're not
everybody but like most of the people
or if not not them directly probably
people they know and if you impress them
but the truth of it is um you know
people
just aren't developed enough in their
craft to do
something that's impressive enough to
get to people who can get to people to
get it moving
you know and then uh and instead of just
going okay yeah i'm on the way i'm
learning whatever they go
oh hollywood's closed people
um you know they don't like my type
because of this or that and um
again there is bias i'm not saying there
isn't but it's a tiny part and when you
focus on the bias
you are giving your power away you are
leaking it and you are distracting
yourself from your
greatness and you are
you're just out of alignment from your
deeper goal which is to be in service of
your audience which is all about
coming from your power and being there
and helping them
and in the shawshank redemption some of
the character arcs
went from victim attraction
attracting victim-like um situations to
reversals of that with let's say the
prison warden
so he was maybe more empowered at one
point and then because of
some things that he did then it took a
reverse turn
whereas with red it was so different
character arcs
happen i mean how much should we be
thinking about things like that the law
of attraction
in relation to our characters what are
they attracting
well we shouldn't think about the law of
attraction at all
unless um we like it unless it speaks to
us
unless um we see real value in it
there's
aspects of the way people talk about the
law of attraction that are really
sort of off-putting to a lot of people
and for good reason
um and uh and if you're
you know and if your curiosity stops
there then you shouldn't be thinking
about it
it's uh it's been significantly
beneficial for me and for other people
i've
seen put it into practice things
happen and it feels good and it's fun
and it's easier and it works
that's my experience people should have
their own experience and see if it works
for them
maybe it does maybe it doesn't um
for chocolate redemption in terms of the
victim energy the first thing came to my
mind was that
character that um cracked that first
night so
um so andy dufresne comes in and then
that heavier character
um uh was um
he cracks he was he's the one that just
he gets so
overwhelmed with his fear that um
he ends up crying and i think that the
guard actually comes in
and then beats him down and he dies
because of his wounds so um
and that from a looked at from a law of
attraction perspective was like he
brought that on himself he was
so deeply in the habit of giving away
his power
not being able to feel the terror that
he felt being in this new place
that he spiraled to a place where he
made things worse and he made things
worse and he made things worse
to the point where he actually killed
him right and we all do that sometimes
and we all have the power to do that a
little bit less and a little bit less
and when we do it a little bit less so
often that we actually
almost never do it we just hold our
power and we come from our power more
often
your example about the warden is really
interesting so he starts out clearly
with lots of power
and then comes to a point where but he's
he's completely corrupt
so he's doing it he's not using his
power in service of his people
so um why what's going on beneath that
he's ultimately he's got the material
power he's in charge
but he's not he's not in alignment he's
actually he's a victim and he's
he's a victim even though he's
technically in charge and he's coming
from that victim place
as a tyrannical leader because the
tyrannical leader is not in service of
his or her people
they are coming from their victim energy
so um
so when he falls at the end it is still
saying the same theme that it's always
better to find hope
and and despair and victim energy will
always cycle you down to terrible places
even if you are and that's actually
that's the connection between the two
characters is that you have
the warden who started out very powerful
but
basically was in this energy of victim
and lack and i didn't believe in
genuinely serving people so he had to
cheat and steal and lie
and it basically drove him into a place
of
despair and that character that came in
as the
the fresh fish the uh the guy that
cracked under the pressure was the same
thing but he didn't
he he just his demise happened so
quickly because he came he started from
a place of less power
but they both are thematically proving
the the thematic statement of that piece
that um
that when we hope we get good things
when we despair we get bad things or
from law of attraction language when we
are open to our power um or we
start with the negative part when we are
sort of bringing in
victim energy or lack energy or that
sort of thing it leads to despair
when we bring in our power and our flow
and our ease
and our belief and our hope and our
patience it leads to triumph
should so just the way people sort of
use the hero's journey
yeah to as a backdrop against their
story
if someone is open to the law of
attraction and
whatever woo parts scare maybe some
people others
are open to what what templates can they
apply to their story
with the law of attraction geez
um i don't know if i would call it a
template
it's like um my understanding the law of
attraction
there's been you know people talking
about this probably for
thousands of years in one way or another
but in the 20th century there was
some you know people writing about it
sort of turn of century and then in the
last i know 20 30 years there's been
other people
writing books about it there was that
movie the secret that that was you know
touching on it and um but it's like uh
i don't know i mean it's yeah it's more
of a
it's the tool that screenwriters can
take from it is more of a mindset
approach
it's like look the doors are going to
close in your career
for sure how do you want to respond to
that in a way where you're like oh no
the door closed blah blah blah
that's terrible oh i didn't get into
this you know
screenplay competition or oh this person
didn't buy my script or
whatever it is there's oh this person's
not returning my phone call
um uh you have a choice in how you can
respond to that
and um and when you choose to respond to
that from your inner sovereign energy
as a king or a queen saying i reached
out to another kingdom and
it didn't work out fine i'll reach out
to another kingdom and then i'll reach
out to another kingdom and then i'll
reach out
because you know why that's who i am i
am a king and i reach out to other
kingdoms and i do business when i find
my kindred spirits
and that's just it because this is a
treadmill and i'm just in it
to be here and to do things and yes at
some point i'll find the right person
and we can marry our kingdoms together
and do something amazing and until that
point who cares because i'm showing up
as me
and i'm just doing it
you